fine well thanks so much for coming out
today there's good competition in this
slot so I probably shouldn't have
mentioned that because you might have a
look see who else on at the same time
and realize there's a better room you
could be in but Kevin's all the way at
the top and you won't get there in time
so you're going to have to stay here now
uh thank you so much for coming out this
is really a nice thrill for me because
um
it's only my second in-person conference
since the happening
um and it's been this is where the first
one where I've actually felt comfortable
enough to actually enjoy myself and I've
had some great conversations with uh
with many of you yesterday and looking
forward to a more relaxed time once my
talk is done it's the first time I've
given this talk in public I did it in my
hotel room by myself talking often to
like a fake attendees shaped in the form
of towels and things so hopefully you'll
forgive any uh slight missteps here and
there but I'm not sure this is I'm very
happy with this talk actually so I'm
going back no this is a good talk right
and you'll be applauding at the end
that's what I'm thinking internally but
we're not we're gonna hear talking a
little bit about the meaning of words
now some of you might know me for such
things as microservices that is indeed a
lot of my day job and today's talk is
sort of micro Services adjacent in as
much as it's about a topic which often
interests us when we're looking at any
discussion around Communication in a
service-based architecture of which
microservices are just one type
I spend a lot of my time talking about
boxes
boxes and very importantly arrows right
the arrows are kind of vital in the
whole boxes and arrows story sometimes
I'm talking about how big boxes should
be or indeed how small boxes should be
in other situations we are discussing
what should be in a box
how many things should be in a box
I do especially enjoy talking about the
shape of the box and of course I have my
own personal view which of course is the
correct view which is that all boxes
should in fact be hexagons but today's
talk is actually about the arrows
the arrows between these lovely lovely
boxes this my friends is the life of an
architect how glamorous
is a simple micro service architecture
just to because some of you probably
want to hear a little bit of
microservices stuff
um and I always like to be very clear
about what these diagrams represent
because I think understanding what I'm
trying to share
helps you get the best out of it and
make sure we're talking about the same
things this little micro service
architecture is a logical architecture
diagram and I show arrows here between
these services so this Arrow here
is what I use to denote a logical
dependency
so the arrow here from returns to
shipping defines the direction of a
logical dependency
and specifically what we mean here is
that the returns microservice depends on
some functionality which is provided to
it by the shipping microservice
I think it's a mistake with a service
architecture to think in terms of oh I'm
accessing data
I think more generically the shipping
microservice has some functionality it
implements
and it decides to expose some of that
functionality over Network endpoints
which other services can then consume
and so this Arrow says the returns to do
with part of its job I need to rely on
things that the shipping microservice
provides to me this is kind of the
acceptable face of coupling in the
context of a microservice architecture
and I've referred to this typically as
domain coupling quite a loose or weak
form of coupling in general well when
compared to the others
so when we start talking about how to
implement these interactions the most
common question I then get and this is
going back for many many years now is
should this integration be synchronous
or asynchronous
that's what I get and I actually think
this distinction is not very useful
and we'll get into a why that's really
what the whole talk is about that this
distinction
isn't one that gives us any ability to
talk reasonably about what we want out
of a system
I typically Instead try and start the
conversation talking about different
styles of interaction that we might have
between two microservices and broadly
speaking I've broken the word the world
down into request response or into
communication and event driven
communication
and again this being a talk about
meaning I will now explain what I mean
by these terms just so there's no
confusion
request responsor into communication is
probably the form of communication that
many of you are most familiar with
so in this case we've got a micro
service in this crisis that returns
microservice which is acting as the
consumer it wants to consume
functionality provided by another
microservice to do so in a request
response oriented fashion it sends a
request so in this case here I'm going
to another microservice and saying hi
look I need a shipping label we need to
return this package for a customer
I don't know how to generate return
labels but you do the shipping
microservice looks at the weight of the
package you're trying to send the
location you're trying to send that to
and it generates your label and it gives
you a PDF maybe in the response that you
can then use some people would refer to
this in terms instead of request
response I'll just say request driven I
like to point out that you always do
want some kind of response even if it's
just to know did the thing work
but often because we need the response
to do something else with that
information all because we've got you
know a chain of causality that we need
to deal with
other people will talk about commands
you can see a request as being a synonym
an alternative name for a command I
prefer the word request because request
is slightly weaker which I think is
important when I send a request to
something the thing I'm sending a
request to gets to say no
when I call something a command it feels
much more forceful do
for me these things are much more like a
request to my son to clean up his room
it would be nice if it happened but I'm
not going to be surprised if it doesn't
so I'd prefer request response but I
understand think command if you're using
that terminology is kind of similar to a
request here so the return to
microservice consumes the functionality
of the shipping Market service we move
into one of the adventure and this is
quite different
here we've inverted things
with request response it's the consumer
that initiates the interaction
I need to do something can you help me
please
with event-driven communication we have
an inversion
the consumers in this interaction don't
initiate the interaction they react to
things happening in the system
so here we've got a microservice called
inventory this manages the stock in our
system
and it alerts us to a very important
piece of information and that is that
we've just received 10 000 copies of
Justin Bieber's greatest hits
this is Vital Information now the way I
describe an event just you know another
way of thinking of an event here is to
think of it as a fact
something has happened
and it's an important enough fact that I
want to let the world know
so I communicate that fact but I don't
send a fact to anybody it's more like
putting up on a notice board and then
interesting parties can decide if they
care about that fact
so in this example we have two different
microservices
which both care about this fact but
might do very different things with this
information
the promotions microservice for example
is responsible for automatically
discounting our products based on stock
volumes so if we've got more than say 5
000 items in stock it will automatically
take 20 off the recommended retail price
the wish list on the other hand notifies
people when items that they put on their
wish list are now available in stock
one event two very different outcomes
so in this context these micro services
on the right hand side promotional wish
list are the consumers we see a kind of
interesting inversion and these
interaction styles are very different
request response feels very familiar to
us
event driven is very nicely Loosely
coupled but has some additional
complexity when trying to confirm things
like did anything actually happen I'm a
big fan of event driven interactions
because of that loose coupling nature
this is the city of how I tend to
approach the world of inter-process
communication this tends to be where my
head goes to first I would say the
majority of non-trivial microservice
architectures that I've ever worked on
will end up having a mix of these styles
of interaction there will be things that
you want to do within your system that
just fit one of those styles of
communication really neatly and you'll
annoyingly have a lot of types of
interactions that could be modeled in
either way and this is the beautiful
Bounty of our industry there's always a
hundred different answers to Any Given
question
so then the interesting question is well
what's my problem with synchronous
versus asynchronous well traditionally I
would sort of talk about synchronous and
asynchronous here request response
versus event driven here and then talk
about how they are related to each other
and as we'll see you know we think of
request response traditionally as being
very synchronous in nature
but in fact it can also be asynchronous
we'll see how one way in which we can
make an asynchronous interaction around
request response for some value of the
word asynchronous and as we'll see later
the word asynchronous actually has no
value
um but eventually interaction as we
always think of as being asynchronous in
nature because the things reacting to
the event are based on the nature of the
interaction deciding what they do when
they do it if they feel like it right
and so I often found this kind of way of
thinking of the world quite useful
because rather than say picking a
technology and then working out from
that technology what I could do with it
instead I start by thinking about the
style of interaction I want
and then using that to pick which
technology I want based on other factors
in my environment
however I've stopped doing this a little
bit partly because I've come to the
realization there is no consistent
definition of what asynchronous actually
means
and I was so inspired to do this talk
partly by post by Pat Helen so this is
actually from Pat Helen's newsletter
which is very it's a very sporadic
posting but Pat Helen's pretty smart guy
and in this post he makes the argument
that we should stop using the word the
term eventual consistency
because we use consistency the term
consistency in two very closely
associated contexts but those words have
very different meanings
when we think about consistency in the
context eventual consistency we're
thinking about can two or three or four
replicas see the same data at the same
time that's one of our main concerns
but then we have the term consistency in
the context of an acid database
transaction and it means something
completely different
I mean if you look at the definition of
what the consistency means I'll leave it
as an exercise to all of you it means
something very weird
and his argument is well actually that's
actually got mathematical properties and
you know formal thinking behind it maybe
we should come up with a new term for
eventual consistency and He suggests
eventual convergence which I think is a
better term in the term I'll be using
going forward now unfortunately I'm not
as smart as Pat
so Pat in this post says here's a
problem here's a potential solution this
talk largely is about me going yeah it's
a problem I don't yet have the solution
but maybe you can help me with that a
bit later on
so around this sort of time I was
thinking about this problem with this
issue with this term asynchronous what
does it mean I talk to different people
I get very different views so I did what
any smart rational human being would do
and that is reach out to Twitter
for some well thought through advice and
guidance
remarkably I got some kind of useful
information so from that point of view
you know this might be quite shocking
right
so I'm going to run through some of the
responses I got and this gives you a
sense of the different viewpoints on
what asynchronous communication means to
a variety of different people
so one of the first responses I got was
from an old colleague of mine Darren
Hobbs
and Darren said well to him
asynchronous communication is sending an
email versus having a phone call
okay the variations on all these themes
I thought cherry pick the tweets that
most fit these different ideas
now this the problem is when we see a
definition like this we immediately
start making assumptions that
asynchronous communication will
therefore somehow be slower than
synchronous communication
which is is not the case because the
speed the throughput the latency of a
system is based on a number of factors
and the fastest lowest latency systems
I've ever worked on absolutely rely on
asynchronous communication so this idea
of slow email fast phone call doesn't
quite line up but there is something
about this distinction
that is interesting
so this was sort of rolling around in my
head and I thought well why this Twitter
thread was going on and you know
obviously there were certain
conversations being had that I made
heavy use of the mute button on
um I thought well let's look elsewhere
for where people have put time energy
and work into trying to Define these
terms and I come across the reactive
Manifesto I say come across it this is
one of my favorite punching bags it's
always good to see where smart people
have decided to get together and work
together and try and Define terms
putting their head above the parapet and
I thought I would reward that work and
there's a lot of great stuff in your
active Manifesto I don't agree with a
lot of it and that's okay but because
they they put their head above the
parapet I think it's only fair to take
pot shots at them for things I don't
agree with and cherry pick things that I
can poke fun of so I've seen this with
lots of love for the people that wrote
it I do know some of them there is some
good stuff in here as I say but there
are also some things that just to me
don't make any sense
the later versions of the active
Manifesto try to do a better job of
defining terms which is good so I go and
took a look I went and have a look at
their definition of the term
asynchronous they start off of course in
try in in time on a fashion talking
about what the Oxford English Dictionary
thinks about asynchronous and they say
the Oxford English Dictionary defines
asynchronous as not existing or
occurring at the same time now
interestingly the Oxford English
Dictionary has multiple meanings for
Words as something we'll come back to a
bit later on they have an explicit
meaning for the term asynchronous in the
context of computer-based systems and
that is not what this definition is so
pick the wrong meaning for the word but
that's fine we'll move on the next thing
they say is in the context of this
Manifesto we mean that the processing of
a request occurs at an arbitrary point
in time so sometime after it has been
transmitted from the client to the
server that's what they mean by
asynchronous I'm thinking what does that
mean
again the processing of the request
occurs at an arbitrary time sometime
after it has been transmitted from the
client to the server
and I'm thinking what as opposed to
processing the request before it's been
sent
work
it's like some kind of Doctor Who stuff
going on here do they think that other
types of protocol we or we've got
instantaneous communication look there
were two truths about distributed
systems one it takes time for stuff to
get to from point A to point B and two
sometimes point B isn't there that's all
distributed systems the one thing we
know is time is a thing right so of
course
I have to send something and then it
gets processed this meaning doesn't
really mean isn't very helpful there's
some other stuff in there that is kind
of interesting
they then go and say this is the
opposite they use a different word there
they use the word antonym which is
actually also the wrong word to use
there but we'll let that one lie the
opposite of synchronous processing which
implies that the client only resumes its
own execution once the server has
processed the request
there is a lot of things interactive
manifest that's good I don't agree with
it necessarily wholly so please take all
of this the pinch of salt but look it's
it's it's good to kick something that's
got a lot of attention right I feel like
I'm at least punching sideways rather
than punching down
um
this is interesting though but this for
me isn't necessarily about the
distinction between synchronous and
asynchronous
the client only resumes its own
execution once the service has processed
the request this is about something
different more explicit more discrete
and some of the tweets agreed
so originally Steve Smith responded and
he said that for him if he's thinking
about synchronous versus asynchronics
there's a TCP connection
is open for the duration of a
communication now I know Steve he didn't
mind I was obviously going to poke holes
at this so I said what if I use quick or
UDP as accounts I know the answer to
this of course the answer is um and he
said no he clarify what he meant
which is I assume you're not blocking
for a response so this is getting more
specific this lines up with what we just
saw in the reactive Manifesto so for
Steve
and for at least one aspect of what the
reactive Manifesto authors mean by
asynchronous they mean not blocking for
a response
so this is interesting and this I think
is worth discourse discussing and
exploring so let's talk a little bit
about what non-blocking means
so here's a simple scenario I've got two
Services loyalty and subscription and
I've got another micro service that
needs to interact with them in some way
so one of the things we need to do is we
need to award some points and we also
want to upgrade your subscription now
these things aren't don't have to be
ordered they just both have to be done
from the point of view of the business
process these operations could happen in
parallel
or sequentially kind of that's what left
up to us as a developer
now if we started implementing these
maybe let's assume we're implementing
these as sort of a direct HTTP call so
this could be using rest over HTTP maybe
using grpc which again is just going to
be using the HTTP protocol under the
hood
we might end up with some simple code
that looks a bit like this
so I've got a line of codes the first
line of code here I go loyalty
service.orward points
okay I pass some parameters in
and rest one that's the first response
so I'm going to execute that line of
code and I'm going to block and wait
until I get response
once I get that response I'm then going
to move on
to the next line of code
and so that's when I'm going to make the
next call to the service
so in this situation here
I'm calling you and I'm waiting till you
respond
no it's not it's not it right so now I
go over to you now I know
you have to nod others I can't yes not
it thank you so now I can carry on with
my world right so this is kind of what
it thinking is blocking calls right now
of course we can start to see some of
the issues with blocking calls like this
in this particular context the latency
of this operation is now becoming the
sum of these Downstream calls so if the
first call was taking I don't know 50
milliseconds and the second call was
taking 150 milliseconds our total
end-to-end latency is going to be at
least 200 milliseconds this operation
and actually you know we might you know
one of the things we're often dealing
with in the Microsoft architecture is
trying to reduce the latency of our
systems and so we try and do things like
avoiding long cool chains however even
if we don't have what looks like a long
call chain but have sequential calls
from within a single service we still
have that latency buildup occurring
because of a call happening then a call
happening then a call happening and this
would be visible to you that this is
going on if you're using say a digital
tracing tool big shout out to my friends
at honeycomb go see them on floor five
and they'll show you how you solve all
these we usually see all these problems
occurring in your systems
so
this is this is not ideal
the other thing is it also gets a bit
worse in a way because we have to
remember that the latency for an
operation is not a fixed number
in fact it's dangerous to talk about an
average latency for an operation in fats
because typically we would expect the
latency for say a service call to have a
distribution and so it's more common to
look at them in a histogram you'll often
see you know calls with like multiple
Peaks which can occur when you're doing
say when you're having cash hits versus
cash misses and the like and so you do
get variability on this
and the issue is you then get sort of
you know it could be as quick as two 20
milliseconds in this case or as slow as
70 milliseconds we've got a range of how
long any given operation might take
now if we're making multiple calls
sequentially
we end up with a much much larger range
of potential durations for this
operation that we might otherwise expect
and this is a problem
the more variability you have around
operations latency the harder it becomes
to understand what the system is doing
and whether or not it's healthy if an
operation could could successfully
complete and take anywhere from say 200
milliseconds to a second
it becomes quite difficult for you to
spot when you've got issues occurring
because sometimes it might complete a
second and other times that might speak
to a catastrophic issue you should have
picked up earlier so in general with
distributed systems we're aiming for
consistent and more consistent Behavior
now obviously from a latency point of
view an improvement here would be to do
these two calls in parallel
so that rather than doing one call and
then the second call instead just to run
them both at once
and initiate both calls at the same time
and therefore the overall latency of
that at least this part of our
processing should be bound by the
slowest service rather than the sum of
the latencies
so in this example what I've done is
I've just wrapped these calls
effectively in the future so for those
who don't know a future is a read-only
type for basically a pending operation
it's sometimes you have direct access to
a future construct you know a reactive
extension library and I quite like the
concept of the future so basically when
we create that future here that's the
first line of code here
we're not actually the request has been
kicked off in a background thread of
execution and all of that work is
handled for us by wherever reactive
extension we're using
so that first line of code we're not
blocking waiting it's going to
immediately return with a pointer to
that pending operation
so now
the calls to loyalty and subscription
are being done much more in parallel
these calls are no longer blocking
seems good right this is an improvement
and you know all of you will have
libraries which will make it fairly
trivial to do something like this around
synchronous calls if you've currently
got synchronous blocking calls doing
things like this to make them
non-blocking isn't that difficult at all
without you don't have to change a
communication protocol at all
the issue of course is when we say oh
we're not blocking we're not blocking
it's not blocking it's not blocking but
but um
we uh we kind of do need the answers
so how do we get the answers in a
situation like this so we've constructed
that future
and at this point here we don't know
whether or not those calls are completed
in those background threads of execution
we certainly don't have the results of
this operation we may need the results
we may need to know that these things
worked or didn't work or we might see
some of the return information to do
something else or to return some
information to the user or whatever else
that might be so how do we get the
information
what would I need to do
I block yeah we block so I do something
like an await
I love it when people say oh yeah I've
made my I've made my interactions
asynchronous by using an async await
yeah the await bit means you're blocking
it might be happening in a thread but
you're blocking
so this is
you know oh it's non-blocking but
blocking
but it's also non-blocking but it's also
blocking though isn't it but it's also
non-block but it's also blocking so this
is a more specific term but again has
confusion now this isn't to mean that
doing things like this is a waste of
time absolutely not being able to do
calls like this in parallel can have a
significant improvements to systems
there's another bonus of doing things
like this
so some of you hands up who's heard of
Moore's Law
of course you're all going to put your
hands up now traditionally when I first
started in Computing
uh I'll I'll kind of the the outcome of
Moore's Law which states a transistor
identity will double every 18 months the
outcome we saw of that was just ever
increasing clock speeds so we could
write a program and that program would
just magically get faster without us
having to do any work year on year as
chips got faster some time ago chip
manufacturers really found it more
difficult to just increase clock speeds
and so instead that increasing
transistor density manifested itself in
terms of us having more and more cores
the problem was our programs weren't
necessarily built to take advantage of
those chords
when we do things like this
the LIE depending on the run times we're
using when we create those effectively
background threads of execution to run
those non-blocking calls behind the
scenes we give our run time and the
operating system the opportunity to make
use of those additional cores
so sometimes this will actually Grant
you better throughput by making better
use of the underlying Hardware so
there's still good reasons to do it but
recognize
that
yeah you still might need out blocking
even non-blocking calls may end up
blocking
this is a good thing right I still don't
think there's anything wrong with this
but we're still you know some people
would say okay you're doing non-blocking
calls but you're still just sending say
a HTTP request response flow and I don't
think that's in I don't think that's
asynchronous at all so let's go back to
our Twitter thread to see what's
happening in our Twitter thread so
here's the next one this is from uh
Graham Lee uh who used to be at Cairo in
Australia
and uh Graham starts off by saying the
definition I've been using is the
sending service doesn't wait for
completion
of the receiving service before
continuing and or completing its own
work so there's part of this is about
non-blocking that first part
the second thing he says though which is
where we're getting into another
definition of what asynchronous means to
some people we see together says but but
now I think about it I think I also
expect a temporal decoupling from the
receiving Services availability now at
this point I'll pause and say there's a
lot of competing definitions of what
temporal coupling decoupling means as
well but we can't get into that one
because I've only got so much time but
we'll talk at least about what Graham
means in this context in a moment
another variation on this comes from
Benjamin who says synchronous
communication there's a direct
communication between sender and
receiver async communication there's an
intermediary
involved between the sender and receiver
and both Graham and Benjamin are
basically touching on this idea of
decoupling
of the client you know the temporally
decoupling the client and server using
some kind of intermediary and typically
by this we would often mean a message
broker not exclusively but this is what
often we often have
so the way to think about message
Brokers is as often called middleware
rather than talking directly to the
place you want to send a message to
instead you deliver that message to the
broker and the broker takes it from
there so service a wants to send
something to service B it actually says
puts it gives it to the broker
says here's the message can you make
sure that b gets this when B is
available so if B is currently
unreachable the broker holds on to that
message
once B is available that message gets
delivered
it's a lovely beautiful idea
so this is what Graham thinks of when he
thinks facing is communication it's
temporal decoupling some kind of
intermediary like a message broker and
effectively what we're doing here is
we're offloading this property of
guaranteed delivery
we're going to the broker and if once
the broker gives us acknowledgment
we are trusting the broker to ensure
that message is delivered
now there's lots of different guarantees
that you'll get from Brokers you need to
look at your own documentation to find
out what your broker means by guaranteed
delivery but again we only have so much
time
another comment async communication is
like dropping snail mail in a red post
box and then going on with your life
then one day boom Postman Pat does
something into your house mailbox along
with millions of coupons and charity
mailers
so I know a lot of people here are not
from the United Kingdom and some of you
are also young so you might have a
different version of who you think
Postman Pat is but this is the OG
Postman Pat not that idiot with the
hovercraft right this is proper
stop-mation OG Postman Pat and this was
fantastic show gritty realistic show
about a postman struggling with his life
as a single parent of a cat delivering
packages he might have been married I
don't remember right this idea of the
broker the intermediate like an inbox is
kind of useful right so I'm out someone
comes and delivers posts through the
front door
it's in my letterbox when I get home in
the US obviously they have post boxes on
the edge of the property because if you
go onto the property you'll get shot so
here we that's why but anyway you get
the idea though I'm not at home right
now and I know things have been
delivered for me I don't have to be
there to receive the package and that's
great and in a distributed system where
one of the fundamental truths is
sometimes the thing you want to talk to
is not available having something which
can act as an inbox is incredibly useful
especially if that inbox has good
durability
and there's actually a bunch of
different variations on this you don't
have to use a message broker you can
actually use databases for this although
you probably shouldn't for communication
between Services file systems are
incredibly common as well for doing this
I create a file I drop it in a location
and another service picks that file up
you're using the file system there as a
durable intermediary
we don't have any smarts around being
told when the new file arrives except
for our ability to pull the file system
but again that's something built into
all the common libraries of languages
I've ever used well in the last five
years at least
we can even do this with email
this also should be filed in the just
because you can communicate between
services using email doesn't mean you
should
email as a reliable message broker has a
lot to be desired
the key thing here
is I don't need to worry about whether
or not the recipient is currently
available it's a nice property but we do
need to trust
that the intermediary is good isn't
going to fall over we have to put our
faith in that which means not just the
people who wrote that broker using a
message broker but also the people that
run it this is why I always try to use a
managed service because people who want
to manager services are always smarter
than me
but again your mileage may vary
now I mentioned at the beginning that we
traditionally see request response-based
Communications through the synchronous
light but I mentioned that you could
absolutely make request response
asynchronous and we sometimes we've seen
one version of asynchronous request
response-based communication just by
making it non-blocking
whatever that means here's another
variation on asynchronous request
response when we think about using a
broker
so service a is going to send a message
a request here to service B we're going
to ask service B to do something and so
I put it into a queue
for like four microservice b b consumes
the message
in this case the request from that queue
I do some work
and I remember B is going to pick that
up when it's ready
and when that work completes
it's going to put its response back on
another queue
and back the response comes
there we go isn't that nice this is
asynchronous oh
this is asynchronous request response
via broker
who knew kind of powerful works really
well
the challenge of course well this one
what this does though is it does expose
another interesting problem
the way most brokers work
it's not possible necessarily
to guarantee that the response is going
to come back to the same instance of a
microservice that sent it
so far I've mostly been showing a you
know a very logical view of a
microservice but in reality when we
deploy a microservice we have multiple
instances typically for Baseline
durability right you don't get an SLA
for machines on the cloud Ergo you want
to have multiple copies of your
microservice instances to tolerate those
notes dying so I might have multiple
instances of service a and in fact
service B so when I send that first
request to that queue and B picks it up
at some point B does its processing and
it sends back the response that response
goes back on the response queue
that response could go back to a
different instance
of that microservice
so we have to code a in such a way that
it can handle that return value coming
in
and be able to effectively if there is
sort of a causal train pick up
processing again
effectively this encourages us to make
these things much more stateless
now if you build a system where you say
no no the original instance that since
that request has to get the response
back the next question to ask about is
why well often the reason why is because
you're holding on to state in memory
I've sent that request over a broker and
I need the response to come back here
because I need to kick carry on that
processing and I'm holding state in
memory
so now I've got the complexity of
somehow trying to effectively do session
based message routing which is an added
complexity and then I ask the question
what happens when that machine dies
oh that's okay you say because I've used
some kind of system for replicating in
memory State and I'm like what are you
doing
this is not the way the world works just
stop it just make your system work like
this and everybody's happier it'll be
more robust and more scalable and your
right code which is much more stateless
and the world's happy unfortunately the
vendors are crying at this point because
there are lots of vendors that sell
complicated software for doing in-memory
replication of state now to be fair
there are some problem program
programming problems where maintaining
in-memory State across multiple requests
is required
um sort of in-memory processing grids
online Shooters and other games online
because the latencies involved
absolutely they represent probably less
than five percent of the world's
Computing problems you're likely not in
that five percent if you are you know it
okay so keep your stuff stateless
we don't have that here
coming back to our previous example
when I'm making those calls
I want you to do something I want you to
do something and I'm waiting for you
both to come back
so both the responses here could come
back
but they're going to have to come back
to the same instance that's kind of
implicitly what's happening here I've
opened the connection from my process to
your process it's coming back here
so we know the responses are coming back
to the same instance
so then we should ask the question like
well what happens when the consumer
either process running this code dies
halfway through
well we're going to lose those responses
they've gone bye hopefully they weren't
important
and hopefully we can retry this
operation
so just something to be aware of what
happens we often think about what
happens when a when the service we're
talking to dies but what happens when
the client sending that request dies
halfway through do we know how we're
going to recover from that situation
I would also say this style of
programming can often lead you to making
more stateful type processing happening
in your client code which again has the
problems I outlined before but I think
it's arguable
that having an intermediary like a
broker forces you to think about some of
these issues and in turn encourages more
stateless processing so it could be a
good thing although we've now got the
added complexity of a broker
so we've got lots of different
definitions we've seen of what
asynchronous mean to some people for
some it's about immediacy the phone call
versus email for others is about
temporal coupling whatever that means
others view it in terms of non
non-blocking and others think oh no it's
about a broker and I'm like what are we
what is it again
which one
and of course then the next question
you're gonna ask is does it matter
right words have different meanings
now I suspect some of you might know
this does anyone know the word in the
English language with the most different
meanings
put your hand up if you know what it is
good
set yes set
so in the 1987 edition of the Oxford
English Dictionary which is the most
recent edition of the full oxen English
dictionary set has the most meanings
they think in the next Edition which is
coming out believe it or not in 2037 I
believe it's a big book it's actually
multiple volumes we think is now going
to be run
so set has only 430 meanings
only 430 meanings run they reckon at the
moment has about 645 different meanings
now of course yes we're talking about
the tenses of these words as well but
you know there are we are used to using
languages that have lots of meanings and
English is no different so like what's
the big deal we clearly deal with this
so here's the thing right when we get
given a word we see a word
the meaning of that word to us how we
derive that meaning is about our own
understanding it's about our own context
if I say the same word
to two different people they might think
different things about it because of
what just happened to them
if I said what does run mean to you and
you've just been out for a jog you might
immediately be thinking of or run means
running
you bring some personal context into it
one of the beauties of being at
conference is like this is getting to
have chats with interesting people and
on Tuesday I had a nice chat with Ian
Cooper and many of us have a hinterland
Ian Cooper's Hinterland is vast and of
course it turns out he studied semiotics
at University semiotics is the study of
meaning believe it or not
um which yeah it might be my next Jam I
think anyway
and he and you're paraphrasing something
you said to me and I was talking through
these ideas he said
the meaning of a word becomes more
narrow as we add other words around it
if I give you a word in isolation and
give you no other words or explanation
around it the only meaning you can
derive is your own personal meaning but
there's still a wide variety of
different meanings you might take from
it as I add more words around that
initial word
the definition the meaning becomes much
more narrow
what's he talking about semiotics you
know
if you want to start dipping your toe
into semiotics I can thoroughly
recommend watching Community the sitcom
because you'll start getting a sense of
how that works there
let's think of the word run
so this run I want you all to think of
what run means to you picture it in your
head what does run mean to you
okay I don't need to use that out loud
now I'm going to put some words around
it and let's see if my meaning of the
word run matches your word of the
meaning run
the issue got worse the moment the
program was run
okay
so I put some words around it and for
many of you the term run now means
something a bit different to what you're
originally thinking in your head let's
try that again
the economy crashed due to a run on the
banks
a different definition a different
meaning rather of the word run
the issue is when we're having
conversations about technology and
what's the right way to do things we
throw away round terms like asynchronous
without anywhere near enough context to
allow people to derive a shared meaning
why is a shared meaning important
well because fundamentally software is a
socio-technical system
this being a talk about meanings let's
derive let's talk about what
socio-technical means it sounds like a
very expensive management consultancy
term doesn't it and indeed if you hire
my services it can be
but let's talk about what
socio-technical means socio-technical
socio people humans human beings Being
Human people and Technical we mean
technology in the kind of the more broad
sense of this term being sort of complex
knowledge
and now you're starting to say oh hang
on Sam you're going to say that somehow
like people are involved in writing
software like some kind of left-wing
Guardian reading beardy Lefty liberal
snowflake wanker and it's like well
actually you know the term
socio-technical actually comes from a
study into the efficiency of coal mining
in World War II so no this doesn't
necessarily come from a bunch oh there's
probably as a bit of a healthy overlap
between people studying coal mining and
guardian readers but anyway you know the
term it's been around for a while this
term and we've now been maybe in the
last 10 years or so been looking at this
concept in the context of software
because we have to reflect and be honest
with ourselves that the amount of useful
software that's created by individuals
is vanishingly rare
to the point what I'd say is it doesn't
happen
you can think of individuals who may
have started an influential project
the Linux kernel was written by Linus no
it wasn't
I bet you he's not the he hasn't written
most of that code
software is created by teams of people
maybe not teams but lots of people
working together to create something we
have to bring groups of people together
and they have to be able to communicate
effectively to build useful things
if you've got two people and you start
banding around terms like asynchronous
but you have different Visions in your
head about what these things mean and
you think that with these different
definitions of a term like this you can
come together and build a system
successfully
things can go badly wrong
now we have some interesting stories
that we can draw upon to see this
problem firsthand
we have the story of the Tower of Babel
from the Old Testament
and in the Tower of Babel there were one
people with one language
we never find out what the language is
but we can probably guess right and
there's one people they're getting on
really well they've all using the same
language and they're building a
beautiful city and they're building a
beautiful Tower and in the story like
the Old Testament God apparently goes
you know oh look they're doing really
well there's nothing they couldn't do
let's mess with them and then he comes
down and he says you've all got
different languages now
and lo the Tara Babel doesn't end up
getting built now I always thought in
the Old Testament there was some
explanation for why the Old Testament
God did this but not really
just seems that the Old Testament God no
matter what your beliefs are the Old
Testament God a bit of a dick so we know
like this is this is a thousands of
years old story
that speaks about the importance of
people speaking and being able to
communicate clearly to deliver
interesting and
powerful things
coming back to our context the term
asynchronous
in the context of inter-process
communication has so many meanings that
it is effectively meaningless if you use
that word in isolation
and you what you I tend to find is as I
put more words around the word
asynchronous I no longer need the word
asynchronous in the first place
so what we do with this
when you're thinking about the thing
you're trying to build understand what
is it that my application needs
talk about how it should handle
different situations talk about his
desirable characteristics and get
specific as possible about the general
ways you expect it to handle certain
common situations
what should happen when a server is
unreachable how are you going to handle
that
how fast do you want it to be
putting his numbers around things is
always good I find what should you do if
the client crashes
and use and develop more explicit terms
even if it means locally
coming up with your own internal terms
to Define things to make things more
clear
an old colleague of mine that price is a
great talk about how event storming was
almost a disaster by the company where
he worked and that's because partly
because there are lots of different
people coming in different contexts and
they all had a different meaning of what
the word event meant for some event was
something an Event Source system for
others event was about communication
between things
and it ended up being a giant mess and
so they ended up actually having to use
terms like historic fact to distinguish
between different usages of these things
so maybe you want to come up with your
own internal terms which are more
specific within your context
say things like clients should wear a
possible be non-blocking you should try
and run operations in parallel but we're
going to give you the visibility to see
when things could run in parallel again
go Talk to Honeycomb on floor five tell
them Sam sent you I get no Commission
or we are going to use broker X as an
intermediary so that we can do XYZ be
more specific
but don't try and use this as a way to
gatekeep language
or make it about a power play about
correcting other people
so in The Princess Bride this is a bit
of a
I haven't quite used this as a way it
should be used in a way because
obviously in the film which you should
all watch because it's a brilliant film
we have this situation where vinicus is
running around saying inconceivable a
lot and the joke of course in the film
is that we all kind of do know what
inconceivable means and vinicus is
clearly not using it correctly
right and so this is this is what the
conversation is about you keep using
that word
I do not think you it means what you
think it means and he's being polite
here but in a way that's like yeah you
are kind of wrong
don't if you're trying to have
conversations with your colleagues about
the terms and the words they use I mean
I think in game on toys doing it fairly
well
and it's something irresistible about
Mandy isn't it but anyway you
you could afford to ask a variation on
this
so next time someone says
we should make you say synchronous maybe
just ask
what does that mean to you
and you might be surprised
okay that's me we've got time for
questions I have a book please buy my
book I have a child to support
um
and if you want more information about
the work I do so over my website I'll
get the slides for this talk up on my
website once I can get this website
rebuilt and I'll send around a tweet I'm
also over I'm just Sam Newman at hacky
Durham over on Macedon as well and I
hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference if you aren't going to hang
well as you leave please do vote but we
do have time for some questions if
anyone has a question for me
go ahead
one that tweets uh
did anyone mention the definition of
asynchronous being out of order
communion so the question was did anyone
mention asynchronous implying out of
order communication I'll be honest with
you that threat was 18 months ago I
don't recall that being the answer of
being a thing I mean out of order
communication is often something you
have to deal with face to face when
working with intermediaries So within
within Brokers now some message Brokers
will order things for you sort of what
you might class as say traditional
message Brokers like rabbit mq and
things you will get guaranteed ordering
within the queue
within CAF you only get that within
partitions so different intermediaries
are able to give you ordering or not so
I think that's probably not
um it's not something I would take away
in the context of asynchronous however
it's something I would be worried about
depending on what I'm using for
communication because some communication
will offer one if you read from two
Kafka partitions you're going to get
stuff out of order that's just that's
just life
so it's more something you have to be
aware of around specific technology if
that makes sense
another question
any other questions for me
now what's going to happen is you guys
have no questions and then you're able
to come running up and ask me questions
afterwards so go ahead
when you have this actress single
threaded and then you they sort of they
don't need to
deal business
so the chap in the akka.net T-shirt
suggested that we use actors
now I'm poking fun right right it's a
lot of work I mean that because it is a
you know academic that's a big
undertaking
um I don't think that you now you've got
to Define What actors are
so you haven't changed the problem my
problem my question here wasn't about
should we be synchronous or asynchrist
my conversation was here about talking
about the properties you want and the
actor model there's actor model inside a
process boundary
and then as actor model across a process
boundary and those are very very
different things
so I've seen people using the
actor-based model and they think about
it just as passing I'm just basically
calling methods and an object that's
what it feels like when you get a nice
abstraction like akka gives you
you don't really realize you're doing
anything special
right I'm just calling methods on
another object and then people start
Distributing their active-based systems
and they start making fine-grained calls
between those things and I know that's
not the goal of those sort of systems I
think that Souls problems that just says
pick my term rather than somebody else's
term to be fair at least there is a bit
more terminology around the concept of
What actors mean
um but yeah
go talk to chat about akka.net if you
want to know more about it
what else we got we've got a question
over there in the middle
well depends you know I wasn't sitting
there waiting
yeah
um yeah I mean that's the thing that
would be a form of asynchronous I'm
waiting around I'm not waiting around
for that person to operate however if I
was writing an article
or doing a presentation
that needed the answers I would have to
wait so I got enough answer to write the
presentation
and I put that tweet out 18 months ago
and 18 months later here the talk is so
maybe not for the individual tweets but
I kind of did have to at some point
block and wait till I had enough
information to do the talk
wow
that's quite clever good question though
I like the question that's an awesome
one thank you
um what else we got who has got a
question for me
now I've got a question for you hands up
if you're doing asynchronous
communication between your processes
based on the conversation you just had
so very certain are you sure of
yourselves aren't you later on go chat
to someone else right well exactly there
you go that's the right answer but
afterwards go maybe track someone else's
Communications some people's hands up
there and ask them what they do and you
know what you find might shock you as
well
um
but yeah just be clearer
any other questions at all about any of
these things I promise I won't poke fun
go ahead
yes good question so how did you learn
between precision and technobabble and
it's sort of interesting because some of
the things you can when you do have
terms in a complex domain like ours that
can have different meanings sometimes
what we do is we bring a new word in to
try and give it more specific meaning
this though that unfortunately just
increases the vocabulary that you have
for a particular domain
so okay we're not going to use the term
eventually consistent we're now going to
say eventually convergent I've now got
to explain what convergence means
I honestly I don't know the answer to
that
I kind of it's also a bit unfair for me
is because most of my job is often
helping to educate people about what
these terms mean
and I'm not sure the answer
um I think what it helps is to often try
and get feedback from people that are
not as in the domain as you are yourself
so you know when I write the book for
example I would purposely go out and get
people that don't know microservices
that well but do no computing
and they'd go what's this mean what's
that mean what's this mean I think
that's all you can do if you're a tech
if you're somebody inside an
organization for example who is there to
communicate on ideas or share about
ideas you're a technical leader for
example
I think it's important that you actually
go out and chat one-on-one with people
and use these terms and get feedback on
them and tune what you're saying and how
you're saying it
a lot of the time I will go to
presentations about topics that I
already know really really well and I
nearly always come out of them with some
other way to express ideas in a better
way than I could
honestly a lot of it's just I think just
practice and triangulation and
triangulating with your audience thanks
knowing your audience as well
so I've done like a couple lectures and
things like on a master's program and
you go in and you have conversations
there these are people that have never
worked in Industry before so you have to
try and collect your language however
they probably know more about consensus
algorithms than I ever will I don't I
can't break it to them that yes they
might be able to tell me how raft works
but their day job is probably going to
involve taking data out of a database
and putting it on a screen and maybe
taking that data off a screen and
putting it back in the database but you
triangulate your your meanings I think
based on the audience all you can do I
think that's all you can do all study
semiotics but I don't I don't have the
time for that right now I'm going to
that we'll I'll look it up on me I'll
look it up on Wikipedia that'll probably
be enough
it's tough but you're right it's
absolutely it's tough go ahead question
yes so so around my terminology when I
when I talk about
um request response if I wanted to send
a request to multiple people I would
just send it to multiple people with an
event when I so if you think you're the
service and you you post something up on
a notice board
you don't necessarily know who's going
to look at that it could be multiple
different people could come and look at
it the terminology I tend to use as I
talk about request and response for
request interaction and the event in the
adventure of an interaction but yeah if
that events fit really nicely in any
situation where you've got kind of a
multicast you often don't want multicast
requests because if you think about the
nature of apis I'm not going to go and
make the same API call on 10 different
microsources because those 10 different
microservices are doing different things
um so that that's kind of how it's a
tradition typically most multi-car
situations tend to be more event driven
I hope that kind of makes sense though
any other questions question write that
back
well yes and no because again they're
using the term asynchronous in probably
an acceptable context the person who
wrote those libraries was thinking about
asynchronous in the context of a single
running process
so we then take that term of
asynchronous which is that narrow
confines makes sense and then we use it
to wrap course on other service so we're
almost overlapping those contexts so I
don't I don't really know the answer to
that
um it's weird because I did actually go
back searching into all the prior art of
where people use terms like asynchronous
and things I looked at tandem Bound for
example tannenband only uses the term 11
times in the whole District of systems
books I think he looks at that term I
went nope
um but the reactive extension stuff I
mean there might be a and actually what
Pat Helen does in his original article
he said look the term consistency in
acid
has that concept of an asset transaction
has been around a lot longer than us
talking about eventual consistency so
his proposal was we let that prior art
word remain
and we come up with a new term a new
word
um
so I I don't think I don't think we can
blame the people who write the library
because they were writing it in one
context and using it in another context
but we can afford to make that less
confusing
there's no reasons why you can't take a
library like that and wrap your own
abstraction around it that for your
context uses better clearer language so
that for your own developers you add
meaning
I think that's probably probably the
best we can hope for but yeah we can
also blame people that did loads of hard
work as well because that's always fun
sorry reactive Manifesto authors
any other I thought time for one more
question go ahead
yeah so the comment was so in the
context of say a document or a
presentation you can take the time to
build up sufficient context around these
Concepts that they have better meaning
how do we do that in code
um
I mean some I mean a lot of it I mean
part of this is a lot of what we use
refactoring for is to try and rename
things to give them more meaning I don't
I think there is this idea though that
we can just jump into a code base and
that's going to be enough that's going
to be sufficient and I don't think
that's true so hypothetically let's
imagine you worked at some kind of I
don't know newspaper right and you jump
into a code base based on that and you
start to see words and you start to see
terms being used in that context you
might get some understanding about what
that means but you might actually also
need to go and ask a reporter or an
editor what those terms mean as well I
don't think we can as we can have a
piece of code perfectly communicate both
a technical context and a domain context
where we assume that no other
information is being given I think all
we can assume is that miscommunity
misunderstandings will arise from that
I think good code that's using say
ubiquitous language of your domain
can actually make the communication
outside of that code much easier
when I do read that documentation I do
speak to that business stakeholder they
use the same words that are in my code I
think that's that makes the whole thing
work together but again I don't think
you can look at the code just in
isolation it wants to reinforce that
context not contradict it when it
contradicts it that's when things get
really bad that's been taking some
business people don't talk to each other
all right I think we're probably going
to call it on time I'm happy to hang out
and ask more questions but I know some
of you need to go get coffee and
everything else and I think we've got a
fairly tight turnaround for the next
session so I'm gonna start packing up
you've gotta I've got to do a very quick
thing for my my very talented colleague
over here um so I probably got time for
you might have to hang around while I do
a quick video but then I'm happy to ask
and answer questions but thank you so
much for your time
[Applause]